hey guys welcome to gamespot universes
recap of agents of shield season 4
episode 3 I'm buddy i'm here with tony g
comic genius Tony let's get right into
it man some stuff happened in humans
were blamed there's some power outages
people people always want to jump on the
Inhumans what actually happened so to
watch dogs anti-human group to watch
dogs they basically frame they set up in
humans make it look like they're taking
all these cities hostages but they're
really being funded possibly by this
evil senator who hates in humans now
they got all this crazy tech they're
going global bad news for Inhumans and
that can be fun times uncle Eli is
mentioned the guy that possesses Robbie
rayas in the comic books is it still
possible that in the show he's the one
that lights Robbie's head on fire
doesn't look like it cuz in the comics
he was dead it was like his spirit
possessing him and he was like this
serial killer in the show he's in a
penitentiary for attempted manslaughter
but Robby's like he was a good man that
did a bad thing and like the guy that he
bit up was real criminal so it's
possible he's still alive not possessing
him but he worked at the lab board a
ghost were so that could beat a
connection maybe he was infected by the
dark hold and don't know we'll have to
wait and see that happens a lot with
this show we'll have to wait and see
wait and see wait and see so all right
gangsters stealing Gabe's wheelchair it
happened in the book I mean it's kind of
an inciting incident but like this time
Davy Daisy's there Gabe Caesar do some
stuff what happens yeah sort of fighting
you mean they get there just time quake
uses her powers snap Gabe sees it so
then later he's like your deck that
criminal or that wanted person quake you
need to get out of here my brother needs
to be around good people you're not good
I won't tell authorities if you hit the
road before he gets back Gabe has no
idea that his brothers headlights on
fire he doesn't know I mean he knows he
wants good people around his brother
maybe he suspects something that he's
got anger issues but I don't think he
knows he pulled
that was good that's that's really good
man at the end of last episode episode
two mm-hmm may is dying of the ghost
crazies so we're like dude what is the
new what is was Jeffrey mace doing with
her he's taking her on playing and kohls
like we do that so it turns out that and
one of the other infected gang leaders
died it was scared to death right so
they don't know what's going on so Sims
like mais gonna die in 24 hours they get
her back she was in a CDC place they
take her to dr. Radcliffe Radcliffe
figures out it's her that part of her
brain she's having living nightmares we
need to reboot her brain like a computer
but she doesn't have the button you
can't just hit the home screen they need
to kill her and bring her back we have
to restart the brain so the killer the
injector she's out there about the clear
resuscitator power goes out dan so
luckily Radcliffe has his his lmd his
life model decoy hidden in the closet so
he's like it's dark you know Simmons is
busy takes a power source brings me back
may is fine now where am I that isn't
actually confirmed though you don't see
you know you know that she's in the
closet he has a shielded power source
right you don't actually see it but you
can kind of like LMDS are already saving
lives yeah they're already doing good
things yeah cuz he had to hide her cuz
they're not ready to know about her yet
last point senator nadir is a shady lady
uh what she has a connection maybe yeah
so she's talking to some wonder like we
killed 17 in humans and she's like good
and then so it turns out you know she's
talking to her brother she leaves and
then you see her brothers in a terror
Genesis cocoon so he's an inhuman who
hasn't completely transformed yet she
hates in humans but her brother's an
inhuman hypocrisy hypocrisy all right
looking forward to next episode you went
to comic-con I did and you kind of have
a bit of a man crush you know what I'm
gonna let you tell the story who'd you
run into what you asked so I talked to
some of the cast and I talked to Chloe
Bennet I was like hey what if they
brought back
Brett Dalton what if they brought back
grant Ward is an l md and then Chloe
said I don't think they will what if
they need someone to infiltrate Hydra
and Nikki's try to they'll know he's
dead I would love to hang out with Brett
more Brett I don't think will do doesn't
look good for ward in the future uh
thanks Tony thank you guys for watching
for more on your favorite comic books TV
shows and movies keep it locked to
gamespot universe thanks guys